LIMIT TO THE NUMBER OF TIMES A
HOUSE CAN VOTE TO IMPEACH OR NOT
A PRESIDENT.
>> Sean: WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY STEPHANIE GRISHAM.
I HAVE TO BE HONEST, MY TEMPER,
IT IS HARD NOW.
EVERYBODY IS FAIR GAME.
I GET THE BEATEN OUT OF ME EVERY
DAY, I CAN TAKE IT.
DON JR. CAN TAKE IT, ERIC CAN
TAKE IT.
WHEN YOU'RE GOING AFTER THE
FIRST LADY OR A TEENAGE KID,
THIS IS A LINE THAT IS CROSSED
BUT YET THEY JUSTIFY IT.
HOW COME THAT IS ALLOWED?
IF IT WAS ANYBODY GOING AFTER
SHORT OF MICHELLE OBAMA SAYING
FOR THE FIRST TIME I AM PROUD OF
MY COUNTRY, BRING YOURSELF INTO
THE ARENA, PITTS HAS CROSSED
LINES WE'VE NEVER SEEN.
>> I AGREE ON THAT IS THE
TOLERANT LEFT FOR YOU AND THE
LEFT WING MEDIA FOR YOU.
MINOR CHILDREN OF ANY PRESIDENT
IN ANY ADMINISTRATION SHOULD BE
OFF LIMITS AND THE FACT THAT
AFTER THAT PROFESSOR SAID THAT,
THE ROOM ERUPTED IN LAUGHTER WAS
BEYOND THE PALE, REALLY
UNFORTUNATE AND WHAT WAS ALSO
UNFORTUNATE WAS SOME MEDIA SEEM
TO REALLY REVEL IN IT.
PBS DATA, THE VIEW DATA.
WAS REALLY UNFORTUNATE BUT
THAT'S WHAT IT IS WITH THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION RIGHT NOW.
>> Sean: YOU WORK WITH THE
FIRST LADY, GOOD FOR HER
YESTERDAY, I APPLAUD HER FOR
CALLING THIS OUT FOR WHAT IT IS,
AND YOU WOULD THINK THAT THE
MEDIA INSTEAD OF DEFENDING IT
WOULD SAY EVERYBODY ELSE IS FAIR
GAME, IF YOU ARE DISHING IT OUT,
YOU'RE GOING TO TAKE SOME
INCOMING.
THEY DEFEND IT.
HAS IT GOTTEN THAT BAD THAT WE
NOW HAVE TO ATTACK A KID AND WE
HAVE TO ATTACK THE FIRST LADY?
HELPING WITH OPIOIDS, READING TO
CHILDREN.
>> YES.
THE ANSWER TO THAT IS YES.
THE LEFT IS SO ANGRY AT THIS
PRESIDENT'S EXCESS THAT THAT'S
ALL THEY HAVE LEFT IS TO ATTACK
THE FIRST LADY WHO IS DOING
NOTHING TO HELP CHILDREN AND
ATTACK THE MINOR CHILD OF THE
FIRST FAMILY.
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC SEES IT FOR
WHAT IT IS.
THAT HEARING WAS A JOKE, IT WAS
VERY EMBARRASSING AND THIS
MORNING, I THOUGHT NANCY PELOSI
WAS GOING TO COME OUT AND SAY
YOU MADE A MISTAKE, LET'S GET TO
WORK AND DO USMCA.
THEY HAD TEA WITH WHAT A JOKE
THAT HEARING WAS.
SHE DIDN'T, THEY ARE MOVING
FORWARD WITH IMPEACHMENT.
I THINK THEY WERE GOING TO BE A
LOT OF DEMS THAT ARE HURT HERE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SEE WHAT
THEY ARE DOING WHEN THEY ARE
GOING DOWN THE ROAD OF ATTACKING
A 13-YEAR-OLD CHILD AND
ATTACKING THE FIRST LADY.
THEY ARE DESPERATE RIGHT NOW.
>> Sean: YOU WORK WITH THE
FIRST LADY A LONG TIME AND WHEN
JIMMY KIMMEL -- WE HAD A BIG
FIGHT THAT I WON AND I DARE HIM
TO START IT UP AGAIN.
JIMMY, START IT, ONE MORE TIME.
I HAVE A LOT TO BRING OUT.
I WAS JUST READY ON THE VERGE OF
UNLOADING IT ALL.
BUT HERE IS THE THING.
BECAUSE SHE SPEAKS FIVE
LANGUAGES, ENGLISH IS HER FIFTH,
SHE HAS TRAVELED THE WORLD SINCE
BEING A TEENAGER, HIGHLY
SUCCESSFUL, NICE, SMART,
INTELLIGENT AND GETS ATTACKED
FOR HELPING KIDS AND TRYING TO
END THE OPIOID EPIDEMIC.
AND THEN THEY ATTACK HER TEENAGE
SON, HER 13-YEAR-OLD SON.
ATTACKED HIM BEFORE HE BECAME A
TEENAGER.
>> HE HAS BEEN THE SUBJECT TO
ATTACKS FOR A LONG TIME BUT YOUR
POINT ABOUT THE FIRST LADY IS
EXACTLY TRUE.
THIS WAS ANY OTHER
ADMINISTRATION, THE FIRST LADY
WOULD BE HAILED AND WOULD BE IN
ALL KINDS OF PUBLICATIONS AND
TALKING ABOUT BE BEST IN ALL OF
THE THINGS THAT SHE IS DOING TO
HELP CHILDREN.
BUT SHE KEEPS HER HEAD DOWN, SHE
CONTINUES TO WORK AND IT DOES
NOT BOTHER HER.
SHE WAS ATTACKED THE OTHER DAY
ABOUT THE TOTE SHE WORE AT A
CHRISTMAS VIDEO.
IS NOT BOTHERING HER AT ALL
PAIRED THE FIRST FAMILY IS VERY
STRONG, THE PRESIDENT IS VERY
STRONG, WE ARE USED TO THIS BY
NOW.
HAS HAPPENED BEFORE HE EVEN TOOK
OFFICE.
THAT'S OKAY, THE RESULTS THIS
FAMILY IS SHOWING FOR THIS
COUNTRY IS WHAT MATTERS.
>> Sean: THINK YOU FOR ALL YOU
DO AND FOR BEING WITH US AT MY
OFFER STANDS, JIMMY KIMMEL, I